[Música]
hola a todos y bienvenidos a esta nueva
emisión de los observadores aquí en
france 24 son muchas las noticias falsas
sobre el covent 19 hoy les proponemos
una emisión especial en la que vamos a
desmentir las noticias falsas que fueron
detectadas estas últimas semanas por los
periodistas de nuestro equipo
en primer lugar volveremos a hablar
sobre una noticia falsa que afirma que
las primeras personas vacunadas contra
el coi 19 habrían muerto en españa
francia o reino unido luego analizaremos
un vídeo que fue sacado de contexto
sobre una escuela en nigeria
y por último veremos como la mascarilla
que usó la ministra del interior de
italia causó controversia
1 y se murió de un ataque al corazón la
noche después de ser vacunada pero la
residencia de ancianos quiero hacernos
creer que es sólo una coincidencia
araceli la primera persona vacunada en
españa muere 24 horas después de ser
vacunada
cuando comenzaron las campañas de
vacunación mundial contra el cob y 19 en
francia y españa- se difundió un rumor
en internet que la primera persona
vacunada en estos países había muerto
justo después de recibir la inyección
veamos lo que ocurrió en francia el 27
de diciembre de 2020 mujer de 78 años
quien vivieron una residencia de
ancianos fue la primera persona en ser
vacunada en el país de un acontecimiento
que cubrieron muchos medios de
comunicación pero a mediados de enero
algunos empezaron a pensar de nuevo
morissette y a preguntarse por qué no
hemos vuelto a saber nada de ella fue
entonces cuando comenzó el rumor de que
tal vez había muerto y volvió a aparecer
un tuit del 28 de diciembre mauricette
la mujer de 78 años vacunada en sevran
murió anoche tras un ataque al corazón
yo trabajo en su residencia de ancianos
pero como descubrió la página francesa
de verificación de hechos técnicos la
persona que escribió este tuit después
admitió haber mentido y dijo que no
trabajaba en ese hogar de ancianos y
además de santi vacunas los hospitales
de parís confirmaron que movilicen no
está muerta y que ya recibió la segunda
dosis de la vacuna en españa' esta
captura de pantalla fue compartido en
twitter y whatsapp y parece haber sido
tomada del reputado periódico español el
mundo su primera reacción debería servir
a la página web del mundo donde no
encontrarán rastro alguno del artículo
porque esta captura de pantalla fue
en photoshop una de las pistas para
descubrir que esa noticia es falsa es
que el tipo de letra no es el mismo que
utiliza el mundo y el periódico confirmó
que se trataba de un artículo falso
araceli rosario hidalgo está viva y sana
y también recibió la segunda dosis de la
vacuna
ninguna de las primeras personas que
fueron vacunadas en francia o en españa
murieron después de recibir la vacuna
pánico entre los estudiantes de nigeria
tras el anuncio de la vacuna contra el
hobbit 19 algunos de nuestros lectores
se pusieron en contacto con nosotros
para preguntar sobre un vídeo que había
visto circular por whatsapp el pie de
foto decía que mostraba a los alumnos de
una escuela de nigeria huyendo para no
recibir la vacuna contra el joven 19 lo
primero que hay que saber es dónde y
cuándo ha aparecido un vídeo en internet
escribiendo palabras clave encontramos
el vídeo en twitter y youtube con la
misma afirmación falsa y una vez que lo
encontramos pudimos utilizar una
herramienta gratuita de verificación de
vídeos llamada invita invita extrae
miniaturas del vídeo y busca en internet
para ver dónde ha aparecido antes
encontramos el mismo vídeo en una
publicación de facebook que data de mayo
de 2019
un estudiante de ss2 en port harcourt
llevó armas y granadas de gas
lacrimógeno para una pelea de clase
mientras se las enseñaba a sus
compañeros de tono sin saberlo una de
las granadas y desató el infierno
buscamos algunas de esas palabras claves
en internet y encontramos un artículo en
el sitio web de la bbc en beijing el
inglés pidgin es una lengua que habla en
unos 75 millones de personas en toda
áfrica occidental- traducimos este
artículo que dice que el suceso ocurrió
en port harcourt nigeria en 2019
un portavoz de la policía un estudiante
llevó casi lacrimógeno que se disparó
accidentalmente causando el pánico y por
eso todo el mundo estaba corriendo así
que este vídeo no muestra adolescentes
huyendo de una inoculación de kobe 19
sino de gases lacrimógenos y fue grabado
en mayo de 2019 mucho antes de que la
pandemia hubiera comenzado
esta mascarilla a favor de los
inmigrantes confirma que la invasión sin
precedentes continuará la ministra la
morge se piensan los inmigrantes que
deben desembarcar a toda costa pero no
le importan los sintecho que se mueren
de frío en italia
justo después de la toma de posesión del
nuevo gobierno italiano esta foto
apareció en las redes sociales en ella
se ve a la ministra del interior usando
una mascarilla con el mensaje
bienvenidos refugiados los partidos de
extrema derecha ya la han criticado por
no ser lo suficientemente estricta en
comparación con su predecesor matteo
salvini
en primer lugar veamos las cuentas que
publicaron la foto primavera nacionales
significa primavera nacional y breitbart
italia es la cuenta italiana del medio
de comunicación estadounidense de
extrema derecha cuentas que han tomado
una clara posición contra los
inmigrantes así que hay que proceder con
mucha cautela hicimos una búsqueda
inversa de imágenes y no encontramos
nada en particular pero si asumimos que
es una foto oficial ésta debería estar
disponible en la página web del
ministerio y así es y si miramos más de
cerca no hay rastro de la frase de la
mascarilla tampoco en este vídeo de la
ceremonia de investidura curiosamente ya
hemos visto la frase bienvenidos
refugiados en situaciones similares en
los observadores el año pasado la misma
frase había sido añadida a esta foto
para dar la impresión de que esta mujer
apoyaba la inmigración mientras se
ignoraba a un indigente francés
ejemplo muestran como temas
controvertidos como los refugiados
welcome y 19 se utilizan para difundir
mensajes virales de desinformación y aún
más cuando estos temas se entrecruzan
así que tengan cuidado cuando vean la
frase bienvenidos refugiados ya que lo
más probable es que la noticia sea falsa
y así acaba nuestra emisión especial si
creen haber detectado una foto o un
vídeo falso no duden en ponerse en
contacto con nuestra reacción de una
cuenta de twitter infoblox efe 24 como
siempre si quieren contactarnos para
enviarnos sus fotos aficionadas y
contarnos lo que pasa acerca de ustedes
todos nuestros contactos aparecen en
pantalla hasta pronto
[Música]